what are the top five mistakes you see
people make with short films well
there's a lot of things that are kind of
cliche like one of the cliches that
people always talk about is the short
film or any film really that starts with
the alarm clock going off and somebody
hits their hand on it and that's how you
start the the film and the day of the
character and it makes sense it's the
official start but it's a very cliche
kind of thing that we've seen that so
there's like actual scenes that are kind
of cliche that we're like oh no not
doing that it used to be like vomiting
too that there was everybody had
vomiting in their films that was a
little too cliche-ish and you can do it
cheap too so it isn't like you know we
can't afford to do vomiting just as good
as the feature films
um but it is kind of cliche and people
don't want to see it anymore the biggest
mistakes that specifically for shorts
are too long the shortest too long well
they'll always say that the short is too
long
um quite often music people will put in
a short film music that they don't own
because they you know you can get away
with anything with a short film
um but legitimately you should not have
music in it that you don't own the
rights to so you know it feels so much
better when you put in this Beatles song
you know all of a sudden the production
value seems to go up and it's just
exactly what you wanted and it's a short
you're telling me and with my short I
should do exactly what I want so why
can't I put the Beatles song in
um but if you try to put that up on
YouTube that YouTube will immediately
their little uh you know algorithms or
whatever know that you have that song in
it and you don't have permission for it
and then film festivals you're supposed
to sign something saying I have the
rights for everything in my short that I
am sending in so you know in theory
again they'll know you didn't you didn't
pay for a Beatles song that was shot in
your apartment for five cents
how did that come to be
um and then you know if if in some
miracle uh you know somebody wants to do
something with your film that involves
money later on like they want to show on
an airplane there's very few
opportunities for short films to make
money but if you were lucky enough that
it does
there's a film called Thunder Road it's
a famous example of it that he uses the
song Thunder Road in it they play the
brewsting's Thunder Road he is singing
along to it there's no way you're going
to cut around Thunder Road and there's
no way you can later substitute in
another song when there's interest in it
so he uh did it as a um you know like
kind of like a calling card for his
talent this short film and he sent it
into Sundance just for the hell of it
and got into Sundance where he didn't
have the rights to it
um and then he won Sundance for the
short film and he didn't have the rights
to it and so people wanted to do all the
stuff with it and he didn't have the
rights to the song Thunder Road so he
and everyone always says don't do this
he wrote an open letter to Bruce
Springsteen you know
and so they made a private deal to allow
him to show Thunder Road is on Vimeo no
charge so he's not making money off of
it and we can all see it and but he did
still have to pay Springsteen some money
for it so don't put money you don't own
it and don't have people sing especially
the songs you don't have rights to and
then you know if you do sag screen after
skilled actors There are rules about how
that has to be done so a lot of people
make that mistake if they um they don't
think about that they're going to have
sack actors and they realize they want
it and then they're too late in doing
their paperwork for seg or they don't
realize what it means to have sag actors
because there's a lot of rules about
that so that's a mistake people often
make with their short film and not
understanding what it means to have sag
actors and then a lot of times people
have bad acting because they're short
films they don't have access to Great
actors and they think it'll be fine and
then the acting is just terrible the two
things that ruin both short films and
low budget features but actually all
features bad acting and bad sound
so don't have bad acting and then um
don't have bad sound pay to have really
good sound and put a little money in
post-production for sound too it'll make
the world a difference
so was that five I'm not sure if I hit
five but close enough well and then we
can always add in the bonus one which
we've talked about throughout the
walking
but it's actually it's a great Point
yeah yeah have the person already there
you know exactly start as late as
possible and have them actually there
what do you think about monologues and
short films
well I think it can totally be great as
a short film as a monologue is there um
uh is there a reason that you are doing
that and does that monologue have a
beginning middle and end and what are
you showing are we just having somebody
talk or is there some other visuals
happening beyond the monologue
um there is a short film that showed at
Sundance I for a new wire I used to pick
like the best short films at Sundance
um so it was always a delight to get to
see all the films that we're playing and
then pick which ones were interesting
and different so there's one called I
think it's called Dear Mr Shakespeare
that was a monologue but he had all this
other activity going on beyond the
monologue it's something close to Dear
Mr Shakespeare and that's a fabulous
example of a monologue kind of film
Thunder Road I want to keep on harping
about Thunder Road but Thunder Road is
eulogy so I think that's like basically
a monologue and that's a super
interesting film as well so there you go
already gave you two examples of a
monologue that worked really well I'm
just sorry to go back if someone's
singing even if there's no music and
it's just the actor singing and the
actor sag and everything's taken care of
the paperwork but they don't own the
rights to that song and it's not under
fair use or something so so happy
birthday used to be the thing that
tripped everybody up but now it's not
now happy birthday is back to being
public domain so you go ahead and use
happy birthday as much as you want but
you used to see in older films because
people didn't want to pay for happy
birthday that their birthday song they
would sing when people pull something in
was not our traditional happy birthday
but some made-up song that nobody in the
right mind sings but it is you know they
made it up and it's a brand new song so
there you go
um so yeah you don't want people
actively singing a song that already
exists even though it's not the actual
recording you have to get the sync
license for that song So wow and now I
would assume that's much cheaper than
the actual rights to the music well I
can go into a whole uh thing about music
but basically if you license a song you
have to get the sync rights and the
master license rights and traditionally
what they do is they make them the same
so if you whatever you pay the sink you
would pay the master so you know for
example if you and also you can get
Festival licenses for films that way too
so that you're only paying for rights to
use that song on the festival circuit
and again you're not making money off of
it so you know it's a smaller amount but
if somebody later wants to use the film
commercially put it on a DVD anyone does
that anymore but put it on TV or put it
on airplanes then you have to have the
rights completely tied up so music
rights is a whole headache for both
short films and a little bit of future
right and what I always try to say is
there's so many composers out there who
would be thrilled to write their own
song for you and then you can do the
legal paperwork properly and make
agreements and it should be done for you
know hopefully you can pay that composer
a little bit of money too but um it
should be much more inexpensive and it's
a great opportunity for everybody the
composer gets to write a song or compose
the music for your short film gets a
credit you get something that's unique
to your film everybody wins
what do you think 99 of filmmakers get
wrong with their short films well it's
not fair to say 99 percent of filmmakers
get wrong because there's no wrong or
writing short films and who am I to say
what's right or wrong that's the great
thing nobody gets to decide what is good
for films so there is nothing but I will
say length is always the problem like
hey talk always harp about length but I
think what people get wrong is they do
too long of films or the film that they
have made a five minute film that is
somehow eight minutes but really should
be cut down being five minutes
and who is the one that sort of decides
that like I'm sure so many filmmakers
think well no I need this one scene in
here though
yes I've helped critique films the work
in progress where I will try to talk
forever to convince them that that scene
is not necessary and the filmmaker
insist it is and it's you're making that
film you get to do whatever you want to
do so I can try to push you this way or
that way but it's your film you should
stick by with what you think it is and
maybe that scene means everything to you
and it really is the whole reason you
made the film and that's why you want it
in and I can talk myself blue in the
face try to convince you it isn't
necessary we've already done that point
if you take it out No One's Gonna Miss
it but ultimately you know that's where
you as the filmmaker get to be the final
arbitrator with a short film Nobody Else
is paying for it or making it a
commercial you know man quite often if
you're doing in a school situation
sometimes you have to do what the
professor wants you to do but then you
can re-cut it on your own and make it
what you want it to be and use that one
as the film you show people it's your
piece you're making it expresses you you
should do whatever you want to do
what makes people stop watching a short
film let's say one minute in
so with with anything short film or
feature the viewer gets to decide what
they want you know we only have so much
time in our lives so if you start
watching it and in a minute in you have
no interest in it and you think it's
terrible nobody's gonna put a gun to
your head and say you must keep on
watching it if you're in a festival
situation and you paid a ticket to go
see a program of short films you are
kind of stuck in the theater and you
have to you know watch the whole entire
pieces they go on but um you know the
viewer can decide whether they want to
keep on watching or not the unfair part
is and this is someone who has been a
screener for festivals or um has been a
screener for various contests because
shorts sometimes have a major change at
the end it switches everything out and
makes you think differently of
everything that happened at the
beginning sometimes it's weird or
incomprehensible or something's
happening at the beginning that you
don't understand yet because you haven't
put the time in to hear the rest of the
short and see how it switches at the end
so truthfully because we're going to
give you the benefit of the doubt people
should watch this short film to the
entire day because it really could have
a twist ending that makes it all what
you saw previously now make complete
sense
and also what we said earlier about how
you know sort of the cliches of the
alarm clock
or or vomiting yeah maybe we'll do a
pass on the vomiting I don't know but
you know but we can always make
exceptions like how many great short
films do start with the stupid alarm
clock you know so what we're going to
say they did the alarm clock shot we're
turning this off we're not going to
watch this you you have to forgive it
and there's also only so many ways you
can tell film stories too you know so
um I I say this is a unique voice that
has put something out there that's
special and unique it hasn't had a
million people put their thumbs on it
and and uh give you know criticism or
Tibetan it has certain things to be
commercial so who's to say what this is
going to be or or what it is so I would
never I would not recommend judging a
short film like one minute in
um again maybe it's horrible and cheap
and the sound is terrible but there's a
reason for that then we're going to pull
back and realize this is a film within a
film or something like that